from 1980 to 2008 Oklahoma averaged
fewer than two earthquakes a year last
year they were 585 this year they're on
pace for 870 that makes Oklahoma the
most seismically active state in the
continental US surpassing even
California so what's going on under
Oklahoma turns out there are thousands
of fault lines running under the state
and until recently those fault lines had
been pretty quiet now geologists are
worried that huge increases in fracking
and the disposal of fracking wastewater
near those fault lines might be causing
the earthquakes advanced fracking
technology allows companies to drill
horizontally through shale rock
formations a high pressure mix of water
sand and chemicals injected down the
well creates tiny fractures in the rock
forcing oil and gas reserves back to the
surface
but vast quantities of toxic saltwater
that's been trapped underground for
millions of years is also unlocked at
the surface the oil and gas are
separated from the water and sold to
market but the wastewater has to go
somewhere in Oklahoma almost all of it
gets put down wastewater disposal wells
which inject the water deep underground
into what's called the Arbuckle
formation a thick porous layer of
limestone running under the state that
absorbs water easily and in theory is a
good place to trap all that waste water
but remember all those fault lines
seismologists believe the huge infusion
of water over the last several years has
lubricated the fault lines causing them
to slip and creating more earthquakes
than Oklahoma has ever felt